hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my legends episode 2 video all about
Justice Society careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet so much
stuff happening we you know we have
Victor Garber singing adel wise that was
probably the most back to the future'
ridiculous moment he even made like a
back to the future reference when he did
that we saw a citizen steal get his
powers and we met the full-blown Justice
Society so I know everybody's like how
come they just didn't do that in season
1 why didn't they do it just a society
show well they're probably like a number
of reasons for that I know at least a
couple reasons and partly it has to do
with the characters that they signed as
main actors my hope is that at some
point in the future the characters that
we do have in present day like Supergirl
the flash green arrow all those people
reform a new version of the Justice
Society like they picked the mantle up
listen to the top 10 WTF comic book
Easter eggs there was so much stuff
happening in this episode so number 10
welcome to the Justice Society get rekt
so we have obsidian doctor midnight
commander steel vixen our man in star
girl so it's a pretty classic lineup
with the exception of vixen like she's
kind of a transplant because they were
originally gonna do the vixen character
which I'll explain in a second it's a
little weird with the way they're
explaining things but you're basically
talking about the grandparents of the
characters from present-day
that's kind of the age you're thinking
of so they just explained that they had
to open the episode up with this epic
beat down because that's how comic books
work like the minute you meet another
big team that doesn't know you they
treat you as a threat but number 9 the
reverse-flash is back and he gives the
Nazis a Super Soldier Serum where have I
seen this before this seems so familiar
but he gives it to the Baron who is
actually a comic book character get this
his comic book name is Captain Nazi but
he has superhuman abilities so it was
like the reverse-flash was giving him
his comic book powers so number eight
the Super Soldier was the back door to
citizen steel getting his comic book
powers so you kind of saw it in the
promo for next week but at the end of
the episode Ray gives him that modified
version of the serum they don't really
explain what he does to it but I knew
that it
probably stick and that's how they would
explain his powers but I did like the
way they introduced him to his
grandfather commander Steele with the
dog tags
so we'll say number seven JSA brownstone
they're just full of Easter eggs if you
ever watch the Constantine show they had
a version of the House of Mystery like a
house that existed in multiple
dimensions like a Room of Requirement
that just had Easter eggs everywhere
with magical artifacts like the helmet
of fate so the Justice Society
brownstone is also kind of like that so
be sure when your rewatching this - just
like pause and look around the room but
the biggest one number six the amulet of
ask grant I think is like their version
of the amulet of Anubis it's not the
amulet of fate or anything like that but
I do know a lot of you are wondering if
they're ever gonna do dr. fate it's just
that they're not doing a lot of magic
stuff this season so I'm not expecting
to see dr. fate but the amulet just
gives its wielder magical powers they
just want you to know that if Hitler
gets his hands on it it'll have some
sort of mystical power that'll enable
him to defeat the US Army so my number 5
this is so fun Rex Tyler our man who's
being played by Mike from suits is just
super hardcore and is ready to turn it
into a suicide mission so I just I love
the way each of their characters is so
dead serious on what they do it's a good
way of juxtaposing their team versus the
legends like the Justice Society is the
ideal for what a superhero team should
be like they've already achieved that
top level the legends characters are
just complete amateurs by comparison so
just like every time they got into a
fight they get owned but like the whole
arc of the episode was in recognizing
your own self-worth so like that was
part of citizen Steele's arc he's this
super fragile haemophiliac that
recognizes that he can be a hero the
rest of the team comes to the same
conclusion but I just love how hardcore
the JSA is and they have a badass
soundtrack to like that opening five
minutes of the episode that was the best
thing ever
why don't we have a TV show that's just
that number four meet vixen newest
legend so she's gonna be traveling with
the legends this season and it's
probably gonna be spinning out of what
happened at the end of the episode
finding our man killed by the
reverse-flash and you know just to
explain what's going on
here so the original actress that was
playing vixen last year had a scheduling
conflict so they still wanted to do the
vixen character so the explanation is is
that this is Mari McCabe's grandmother
she is the first person to wield the
amulet so she's the first person to be
called vixen number three was crazy adel
wise back to the future moment Victor
Garber is an amazing performer like I'm
not a huge fan of his Broadway or
anything like that but I just I love how
crazy it is
so I already feel like the energy is so
much better the episodes feel so much
more fun way they're having fun with
time-travel so just everything this
season is so much better number two
course citizen steel getting his powers
I don't know how long it's gonna be
before he gets that comic book costume
I'm guessing at least an episode or two
but number one of course was a reverse
flash killing our man throwing into
question how they're gonna use our man
the rest of the season because it's like
bullet he's dead here is this the last
episode he's gonna be in or is he gonna
come back because of time travel so I do
expect that they'll fix everything by
the end of the season but it seems like
for now this might be the last time we
see Rex Tyler until they like the time
travel to before that in stop the
reverse-flash from going back to kill
him so I know the big question now is is
when is one of the flashes like Jay
Garrick gonna show up to shut the
reverse-flash down because up to this
point he almost seems unkillable because
it's so much more powerful than all the
other characters so just enjoy an
invincible reverse-flash for at least
the next couple of episodes I think it's
gonna be a while before the legends get
some help with that problem but let me
know in the comments what was your guy's
favorite thing from this I feel like we
all want to see a Justice Society show I
think you know if they're gonna go with
the younger actors on another spin-off
series like once arrow goes off the air
a live-action Young Justice would
probably be the leading candidate but
they could also do a straight-up just a
society show so just remind her about
the four night crossover if you guys are
wondering about that they've already
finished filming so they're on the
midseason finales for most of the shows
so we'll probably hear a little bit
about what's going on they've already
started filming the arrow midseason
finale but they're bait they're
basically completely done Shue
all the principal photography for the
big crossover so those episodes won't
drop till December it's gonna be a while
like we're only on the third episode of
most of these and this is only the
second episode of legends so what's
gonna happen next is is I'll do a flash
mirror master trailer video there's some
Doctor Strange Avengers Illuminati Kevin
Feige confirmed that they're going to be
doing Illuminati stuff in Avengers
infinity war so I'll totally do a video
for that and there's some new really
cool game of Thrones there's some
Deadpool there's all kinds of stuff so
I'll try to get that out as fast as
possible but next video should be that
flash trailer so I'll say you know
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner chicken wings you want a $20
Amazon gift card and there is a new
round that starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so get it-- flash
stuff it should be up tomorrow morning
new outro just a little bit different
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click up top for that red
band Logan trailer again and you can
click down here for the guardians of the
galaxy trailer again thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight